I just want to congratulate you you are
beaming and smiling in the ear and
you're just crushing it in your in your
professional life and you're coming up
on seven months I think of marriage yeah
does it feel different how's it been
um honestly it feels like
I don't know Brooklyn's truly like my
best friend so we've been together three
years and I feel like I'm living with my
best friend and also like the love of my
life so it's been nice win-win I'm
married too and that's how I feel yeah
you have to marry your best friend you
do very good advice you have to sit on
the couch with this person when you're
60 70 80 years yeah and you still have
to like each other I was telling you
earlier I spoke with Brooklyn a couple
months ago when he was being honored and
he is just the sweetest sweetest in the
world he was like I want to have 10 kids
I know I've always wanted to be a young
Dad it's like been my dream I could have
like 10 but really her body whatever
it's her it's her decision what do you
make of that number that is really sweet
um well I grew up in a family I've I've
seven siblings
so I think he he loves being with my
family and just being around so many
boys I think he has like built-in boy
best friends now so I think he really
loves that but yeah we we really do want
a big family we want to have some of our
own kids and then we really want to
adopt kids too so Brooklyn said he
thinks you're hilarious and he would
love for the world to see that side of
you potentially in a reality show we
always talk about the most ridiculous
things I'm never gonna say never you
never know is that something that you
maybe see in your future
um no I don't shutting it down well I
would only do it if
um like well my best friend who's also
my publicist and calling her out she's
right there uh we a month ago we started
um it's an Instagram called it's Yogi's
house and we rescue dogs from shelters
from being euthanized on the euthanasian
list
and I would love to maybe do something
with that to show people
the awful situation that's really
happening because I had no idea myself
so we've been doing it for a month and
we've saved like 30 some dogs and that's
something I would love to do oh my gosh
put your executive producer title on it
show us a little personal show us your
charity I would love to see it yeah
thank you I mean do you like looking at
naked dudes I have something to tell you
about women get horny
Dale you're so great as the iconic
Dorothy Stratton how much did you know
about Dorothy going into this well thank
you so much that's really kind of you
um so I watched the movie star 80. it's
her life story and I watched that at
quite a young age and it just stuck with
me for so long because it was so
heartbreaking and and just everything
about it stuck in my head so when I got
the audition I was like oh my gosh I I
know the story I would be honored to be
able to play Dorothy like I I love her
I've never actually played a real person
and so being able to do that was
amazing and and scary because I I want
to I hope people like it because I I
love her so much and I just hope I
honored her oh for sure what I got was a
lot of heart yes you know I love the
physical transformation I mean even just
sitting here right now you're this
beautiful brunette in the show you
really transform into you know the 80s
blonde what was that like sitting in the
hair and makeup chair conceptualizing
your look
the hair makeup and wardrobe on this set
was unbelievable like truly amazing
um so being able to you know when they
put the wig on me for the first time and
they did my makeup and and then I
finally went through um wardrobe and put
on my dress it was really special
because I felt like her so much what was
your reaction when you looked at
yourself in the mirror I was so excited
I I texted my mom like 10 pictures and I
was like Mom look what'd she say she
loved it yeah did did Brooklyn get to
see you on set in your whole Dorothy
yeah wardrobe yes what was his reaction
he he really he was like oh I like the
80s hair
yeah he was like I really like Dorothy's
style I was like okay should I start
changing on my look is there one scene
in this show that you really hope stuns
or shocks or surprises fans that's a
good question I think for me when I read
the script I didn't have a clue that
Dorothy was connected to Chippendales so
I think when she comes up with that
idea it's really cool
cuffs and collars you are a genius
I really loved that I was like oh that's
really cool that she's the one who kind
of inspired from her job brought it to
her husband you know I wish we could
have had more with Dorothy me too
[Music]